hey everyone welcome to this video by
simply learn
in this session we'll be comparing the
three cutting-edge ui development
technologies that is react.js
angular and vue we learn about the key
differences that make them so distinct
all of these technology stacks have been
replacing pure server-side technologies
and we've
slowly progressed from server-side
applications to more distributed
applications where a part of the job is
done on the client side and a part on
the server side
and now we've transitioned to something
known as single page applications or sba
and all of these technologies that you
see on your screen right now are based
purely on javascript
as a result they're lightweight and
aren't dependent on any third-party
runtime tools
so let's compare the three technologies
and learn about the factors that make
them stand out
so let's see what's in it for you we
learn about their features
use cases and where they're applied
their performance how they handle data
the languages they use and the testing
mechanisms we learn about the dedicated
user community that backs these
technologies and finally we'll see the
growth curve
first we'll look into the saline
features now react is a front-end
javascript library
while angular and view are javascript
frameworks now although the terms
library and frameworks are used
interchangeably
they're significantly different now
library is a set of
classes or functions and the user is in
complete control to call them
frameworks on the other hand are like
models they have limited choices and
come with a blueprint of their own
and as a result the user doesn't have
much control so javascript being an
interpreted language where code is
executed line by line
makes all these tools very efficient
mainly because converting the code into
an intermediate code would require a
runtime environment
and would definitely encounter a delay
now these are avoided and as a result
these tools are fast
moving on react is used to develop
mobile and web applications and angular
is used for single page applications and
you can also develop hybrid applications
using the stack
mainly because it's purely based on css
html javascript and jquery
single page applications as the name
suggests are built using single page
now the entire page is broken down into
several components wherein each
component performs a specific task
say for example one component handles
the login the other one would display
icons and images and so on
all these bits or components are then
put together to form a single page
application
and moving on react was developed and
maintained by facebook
while angular was built by google and
view was developed by evan unx
google employee now react represents the
view part of the mvc framework
and angular is a full-fledged mvc
framework in itself
and view on the other hand is focused on
view and the model layer of the mvc
framework now what exactly is the mvc
framework now mvc framework is an
object-oriented design principle that
mandates the separation of control
meaning one thing can only do one thing
so the model deals with the entity
classes
the data and the business logic while
view deals with the representation and
the ui logic of the application
and the controller drives the
functionality of the two
any changes can be easily factored and
isolated and as a result testing becomes
a whole lot easier
moving on now let's look at the use
cases from the business perspective
in terms of react we have top websites
like facebook
instagram netflix that use react on the
other hand we have angular that is used
by
nike forbes sony and vue is commonly
used by alibaba.com
grammarly 9gag and adobe moving on we
have performance now performance is a
very crucial feature now the moment you
build an html view
and render it into the browser this view
to the user is basically just html tags
however if you look at the internal
working the code is actually converted
into a balanced tree structure
this b3 algorithm is extremely fast so
when the user makes any changes to the
ui
the changes are reflected immediately
this is facilitated by the b3 algorithm
so as a result the performance is
improved so how does react make use of
this tool
it uses a virtual dom dom is an api
developed by w3c
it stands for document object model and
defines how the document is accessed and
manipulated
this dom parser converts the html code
into an inverse balance tree structure
so react uses the virtual dom while
angular uses the real dom and vue
uses the virtual dom again now the
virtual dom looks at the differences
between the current and the previous
html pages
and only changes the parts that need to
be updated angular on the other hand
updates the entire tree structure
regardless of any changes made or not
and view again only updates the ones
that have changed
since there is no time spent on making
unnecessary changes to the entire tree
react is extremely fast on the other
hand real dom updation is time consuming
risky and error pro vue also ensures
faster and bug free performance
now let's talk about data binding the
core reason why we would use single page
applications
now consider a scenario where you log
into an e-commerce website as the user
one then you should be able to see the
items in your
shopping cart while user 2 would be
seeing different items in their shopping
carts and so on so identifying the user
and retrieving data corresponding to
that specific user is facilitated using
the help
of data binding data binding is a
process that allows an internet user to
manipulate
web page elements using a web browser
now it is used in interactive components
such as
calculators tutorials games etc now
react supports one-way data binding
meaning you can take the data from the
view and push it to the model or vice
versa
angular on the other hand uses a two-way
data binding while vue also uses a
similar two-way data binding
in react every time the model state
updates the view changes accordingly
however the reverse is not true in case
of angular any changes made to the view
are immediately reflected in the model
part of the architecture
view follows the same principle now this
hugely influences
the performance due to one-way data
binding react is modular and fast
improving the performance angular's
two-way data binding
adversely affects the performance and
view on the other hand performs
according to the input type
moving on to scripting languages react
combines ui templates and javascript
logic
resulting in a new language called jsx
so react only requires a knowledge of
javascript
angular uses templates again in html you
can also inject javascript code into
html using a clever implementation in
angular called directives
so you can create a class and then
inject it into html
angular also does something better you
can also write code for an angular
application using a newer language
developed by microsoft called typescript
it is a compiled language and is very
similar to java and c-sharp in terms of
syntax
now vue again uses html based template
it uses html5
throughout for the ui and the
combination of javascript for business
logic
all view templates are valid html and
can be passed by
html parsers let's move on to testing
now just
is a framework or an api that is
developed by facebook and is used to run
tests on react applications to ensure
that they are bug free now it is
embedded typically in every react
library and requires zero configuration
now angular on the other hand uses the
jasmine framework now this
framework allows various functionalities
to write different kinds of test cases
this also ensures that the application
is error free
the view cli or the command line
interpreter has built-in options for
unit testing with the help of jest or
mocha
now view typically has single file
components and hence these components
can be
tested in isolation this makes it
modular and extremely fast
now let's talk about community support
since all these tools are open source
they have a large developer community
there are a few popular github
repositories for react such as react.js
101
react.js.org and so on you can raise
queries
solve a few and connect with the larger
community that's working on react
here are a few repositories for angular
view also has a few popular repositories
you can commit
download third party plugins and also
explore these stacks even deeper
all of them surely have a very happening
community at the time of writing
there were about 1 million repositories
5 million comments and 1 million
issues with respect to react here are
the figures for angular
and here are the figures for vue
according to npm stat
over the past two years there have been
approximately 360 million react.js
downloads there have been around 38
million downloads for angular and around
63 million downloads for view
now let's look at the future scope
learning a new technology
always comes with questions like what's
in it for me what's its growth potential
how far will it take me in my career
and so on so let's go ahead and see the
growth rate of react angular and vue
according to google trends over the past
12 months
react has been on a way faster upward
trajectory than angular and vue which
have considerably lost their momentum
now this indicates that react is growing
faster than the other two
with respect to popularity industry
adoption and community support
so with that we conclude this session
we've thrown in keywords like single
page applications
javascript component based design model
view controller and a whole lot of other
things
so i hope this video really helped you
gain clarity about these technologies
thank you so much for being here keep
learning and stay tuned to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here